and now you've just come is it Russia
you've just been in Russia during the
tour yes six hours ago Wow yeah yeah
it's very fast yeah well could you speak
Russian don't you I do is it one of
those good things where people don't
know you speak Russian yeah it is
sometimes it's pretty nice when like the
driver has no idea that you actually
understand everything that he's saying
about you it's never really nice things
anyways so you can't wait till the end
of the drive to call him out on it but
yeah I did learn the first time I did
press in Russia how truly different the
translation is like people don't always
translate the right way
okay these base I mean and my coaster I
still get translations in their ears
it's never right it's always it is my
first time I was going hot it's
interesting do they kind of bland out
the questions yeah it's like an
interpretation of the question and
sometimes it's worse and sometimes it's
better which is why it's always like a
different answer at times yeah it's
weird
but now you were just a little girl when
you left was the Ukraine you were born
in yeah it's morning Trinity Ukraine big
town huge have you heard of it huge
there your YouTube
D'Oench we've been doing it for an hour
oh yeah I came with 91 Subin II would
have been very easy just to lose the
language living in the state yeah mom
yeah but I speak question with my
grandparents okay yeah my parents yeah
so still at home you would speak Russian
yeah cuz it's quite a it's one of them
oh god it is mm-hmm I didn't realize
that until it's pointed out to me but
apparently it probably society harsh
language which to meet sounds very
romantic I mean I think it's a great
language but I've been told it sounds
like Klingon like I I'll talk to my dad
and he'll call and be like how are you
and I'm like I'm great he's like I miss
you in I'm like I miss you too how's mom
he's like mommy's great but apparently
to most people it sounds like a lot of
expression and passion yeah it's a very
language oh it's so we I'm being
slightly distractors because while
you're talking I eat so I mean this must
happen all the time but I'm just hearing
Meg from Family Guy poor Meg I do get
the one thing that I get the most of his
shut up Meg on the street
all the time shut up Meg
[Music]
you